[Music]
hey guys i'm matt a producer here at
tasty and today i'm going to be making a
ton of tomato sauce i want to see what's
better sauce from a jar or two kinds of
homemade tomato sauce so i'm going to
prep my station and get started
there are tons of different types of
tomato sauce available at the grocery
store but for this test i opted for a
traditional style sauce for its
simplicity you just pour it out heat it
up and you're done ideal for when you
need a sauce in less than 10 minutes
[Music]
what i noticed right off the bat is it's
super sugary tasting it tastes like
dessert pasta
not into it
this homemade tomato sauce is very easy
and can be prepared in under 30 minutes
the great thing about making your own
sauce is the huge amount of control you
have over the texture and flavor versus
with the jarred stuff you just get what
you get
with this homemade version you can use
crushed tomatoes to make it as chunky as
you want or blend it to make it as
smooth as you please
[Music]
yes making homemade tomato sauce isn't
as inexpensive or as simple as pouring
it out of a jar but the extra effort
rewards you with something much more
flavorful and satisfying
it has much more interesting flavors
it's much more savory much more tomato
in that one i like that it's more chunky
than the other one i'm really into this
if you have lots of time and want a
really fresh tasting nuanced sauce low
and slow is the way to go there are tons
of methods for making a slow simmered
classic tomato sauce so you have plenty
of room for creativity and flexibility
whole tomatoes give you a fresher
brighter flavor than crushed ones it's a
bit more work to crush the tomatoes by
hand but it will help them cook down
quicker
you can use carrots and celery in
addition to the onion if you want more
flavor and sweetness
the longer you simmer the thicker and
richer the sauce will become
[Music]
if you really love the flavorful punch
of onions and garlic feel free to leave
them in
a food mill is a great way to filter out
seeds and skin while giving you
consistently smooth and glossy texture
you can also use an immersion blender
[Applause]
[Music]
from here the longer it simmers for the
better the sauce will get some people
will let their sauces simmer for 12
hours or more
add the fresh basil as close to the end
as possible as it can lose its flavor
the longer it cooks for
yes it takes much longer than both the
jarred and 30 minute sauce but you end
up with a much fresher silkier tomato
sauce
see that just tastes like home the
flavor feels more layered i feel like
you should put this in a jar and sell
that on the shelf cause this is bomb
[Music]
when it comes to price the jarred sauce
is the most affordable though it barely
beats the 30-minute sauce the jar is
also the most efficient taking a
fraction of the time of the others the
homemade sauces offer the greatest
ability to customize both their flavors
and textures but the most important
question is how do they taste when put
to the test my co-workers overwhelmingly
chose the homemade sauces they like the
30 minutes bold tomatoey flavor and the
two and a half hours depth and freshness
ultimately tomato sauce is what you make
of it whether you have 30 minutes or all
day it's worth giving one of these
recipes a try
ah there we go
you